it's the last section of the population
to be vaccinated 12 year olds and
teenagers
they are considered less at risk but
immunizing them has now become a
priority
they are target of the vaccination
because they
absorb the delta virus they don't show
any symptoms
but somehow infect the elderly so
they are the spreaders israel managed to
vaccinate its way out of the pandemic
with more than 80 percent of the
population above the age of 40
having received their two doses for
three consecutive weeks there were no
coronavirus related deaths
israel was hailed as a success story and
the government lifted social distancing
rules
no masks were required indoors and
international travel was allowed again
but that was short-lived those returning
to the country have brought with them
the delta variant and it's spreading at
an alarming pace
accounting for around 90 percent of all
new infections
the country is grappling with an
increase in daily infections now at a
four months high
so the government took the bold move of
introducing
a third dose vaccine a booster shot
at the moment available only for
specific cases
only patients with chronic diseases or
an already compromised
immunity system are eligible for the
third jab
that raises the question of how
effective is the pfizer vaccine
the only one available in israel in the
longer term
health officials say its effectiveness
has gone down to about
64 percent when it comes to the delta
variant
when you look on the long term now we
are looking on longer term it was
supposed to
be reduced a little more chance of
becoming infected
even if it was reduced from 90 to 60
as a fact this is a pcr
positive test positive but this is not
being sick and i'm not
really interested of reducing the
people being positive on the pcr
i want to reduce hospitalization i want
to reduce
mortality still the government is
worried
obligatory face masks indoors has been
reintroduced
and there are new quarantine rules for
returning travelers
more restrictions could be imposed in
the days to come
what happens next is a concern for
everyone
here in israel and for those around the
world who are closely monitoring
how a fully immunized society faces new
mutations
of covet 19. al jazeera
israel